Male describer: A MULTIMEDIA
SLIDE PRESENTATION IS TITLED
"HTML5 VIDEO ACCESSIBILITY
AND THE WebVTT FILE FORMAT.
MARCH 23, 2011.
SILVIA PFEIFFER."
IN AN AUDITORIUM,
A WOMAN SPEAKS AT A PODIUM.
Black: So welcome all.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Naomi Black,
and I'm a member of the
Accessibility Engineering Group
here at Google.
And today,
I'm very pleased to invite
our speaker,
Dr. Silvia Pfeiffer.
Silvia is a member
and an invited expert
on the W3C HTML
Accessibility Task Force.
And she's also
the author of
"The Definitive Guide
to HTML5 Video."
So Silvia's here
to talk to us--
come on up.
Silvia's here to talk to us
today about WebVTT,
which is one of the standards
for timed text
which is under consideration
by the W3C.
Thank you, Silvia.
Pfeiffer: Thank you.
Describer:
SILVIA TAKES THE PODIUM.
Pfeiffer: Thanks for inviting me
to come and speak
about this
important topic today.
We know there are a lot
of discussions going on
about formats
for captions,
and we want to standardize them
for the web.
But standardizing it
for the web
has a much larger
impact these days
than just on web browsers,
just on the web itself.
It goes into many
different devices.
So we're very interested
and very keen
to give a broad coverage
of available technology,
and this is what we're trying
to do here today.
So I'll be talking mostly about
WebVTT, the file format.
But I'll also be talking
a little bit about
how to plug that into
the web browser into HTML
so that in the future,
we have a very simple way
of displaying captions
in web browsers on videos
without having to do
much more than authoring a file
and giving a link to
the web browser for that file.
So it will be very simple
for people in the future
to create more captions.
Describer: SYLVIA CUES
A NEW SLIDE TITLED
"REQUIREMENTS
OF A WEB TEXT FORMAT."
HEADINGS BELOW READ
"CAPTIONS OR SUBTITLES"
"TEXT VIDEO DESCRIPTIONS"
"NAVIGATION OR CHAPTERS"
AND "METADATA."
Pfeiffer: All right,
let's dig right in.
As we were looking
at requirements
of such a text format,
a web text format
for video,
we looked at the different
types of content
that can be time-aligned
with video.
And captions and subtitles
are the obvious ones,
but text video descriptions
are also an important use.
These are for blind users
and can be read out
by screen readers
in parallel to the playback
of the video.
This may well not be
the most usable way
of doing
audio descriptions,
but it is a much easier
way to publish
audio descriptions
for blind users.
And, in fact,
for a lot of blind users,
it may well be
all they need,
because they already have
their screen readers set up,
and it works really well
for some people.
Further to that,
we're also talking about
navigation or chapters,
which is also
very important
for blind and,
in fact, any user.
If you want to go through
a video quickly
and find out
what's in there,
you want to jump to what we now
know as chapter markers.
We can call them
navigation markers.
This can be also covered
with the same kind of format.
And more generally,
metadata.
This is something
that archives
are particularly
interested in,
to attach metadata
to sections in the video.
It can also be done with such
a time-aligned text format.
So what we have
discussed for browsers
is a very simple format.
It's called WebVTT,
Video Text Tracks.
WebVTT.
Describer: A NEW SLIDE TITLED
"WebVTT OR VIDEO TEXT TRACKS."
A SAMPLE FILE IS HEADED "WEBVTT"
WITH TWO ELEMENTS BELOW.
EACH ELEMENT CONTAINS
THREE LINES OF INFORMATION:
CAPTION NUMBER,
TIME CODE START
AND TIME CODE END,
AND CAPTION TEXT.
BELOW THE TEXT, A STILL PHOTO
OF A MAN SEATED IN A WORKSHOP
IS CAPTIONED "I HEARD ABOUT
THIS ARDUINO PROJECT,
AND I SAW IT ONLINE."
Pfeiffer: This is one
of the very simple files
that we can think about.
Just a marker
at the beginning of the file
that identifies
the file format.
The captions or subtitles--
let's call them cues--
then have an individual
identifier.
In this case, it's
the number one and number two.
Could be any string, however.
And then we've got start times
and end times
on each one of these cues,
and a piece of text
in there.
It turns out in--
as we all know how captions
are displayed on screen
in something like this
if it's automatically
created by the browser.
Describer: THE CAPTION DISPLAYS
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN
IN WHITE LETTERING
OVER A SHADED GRAY BOX.
Pfeiffer: That was the very
simplest way of doing subtitles.
Now, we want to do more
than just the simple captions.
In particular,
if we want to achieve
all the functionality
of, for example,
the CEA-608 captions,
then we need to do a bit more
than just text.
We also want to have
some formatting in there.
Describer: ANOTHER SLIDE, TITLED
"WebVTT FORMATTED SUBTITLES,"
DISPLAYS THE SAME STILL IMAGE,
WITH THE CAPTION IN GERMAN.
THE WORD "ARDUINO" IS WRITTEN
IN ALL CAPS AND COLORED RED.
Pfeiffer: Here is an example
on how to do bold.
I'll point to it.
There's a bold tag in here,
so that will be bold text.
Here is some italic text.
Describer: IN THE SAMPLE FILE,
THE SECOND CAPTION CONTAINS
THE WORD "WOW!"
SURROUNDED BY THE HTML TAG
FOR BOLD,
THE LETTER "b" SURROUNDED
BY ANGLED BRACKETS
BEFORE THE WORD "WOW,"
AND "/b" IN ANGLE BRACKETS
AFTER THE WORD "WOW."
ANOTHER PHRASE IS ENCLOSED
IN THE TAG FOR ITALICS,
"i" AND "/i".
Pfeiffer: And up here
we've got a general way
to associate style or a class
to a piece of text
and give it a meaning.
In this situation,
we've turned a piece of text
into red text
and capitalized it.
Describer: THE WORD "ARDUINO"
IS PRECEDED BY THE TAG
"c.red.caps"
WITH A "/c" TO CLOSE.
IN THE CAPTION, IT APPEARS RED
AND CAPITALIZED.
Pfeiffer: Of course,
if we're using this format
also for subtitles,
we need to be careful to cover
internationalization issues.
WebVTT is very clear here.
It requires UTF-8
character encoding.
Describer: ANOTHER SLIDE,
WebVTT FOR INTERNATIONALIZATION,
ABBREVIATED
I18N.
A SAMPLE CAPTION FILE CONTAINS
TIME CODES FOR CAPTION
START AND STOP
AND CAPTION TEXT
IN ASIAN LANGUAGE CHARACTERS.
HEADINGS BELOW READ
"UTF-8 CHARACTER ENCODING"
"RUBY TEXT"
AND "VERTICAL OR HORIZONTAL
RENDERING AND ALIGNMENT."
Pfeiffer: It has a ruby tag,
which supports
Asian languages in particular.
Describer: ANNOTATED ASIAN
LANGUAGE CHARACTERS ARE SHOWN
BETWEEN AN OPEN AND CLOSE
RUBY TAG,
WITH THE ANNOTATIONS
BETWEEN "rt" TAGS
AND THE ANNOTATED TEXT
BETWEEN "rb" TAGS.
TO THE RIGHT
OF THE START AND STOP TIMES,
CODES READ "D:vertical"
AND "A:start".
Pfeiffer: It also does
vertical and horizontal
rendering of text.
Again, possibly one of the most
important ones
are Asian languages,
and I think there are
a few other languages
that are also
rendered vertically.
And we need to make sure
we get the alignment right.
Sometimes text is read
from the right to the left,
so therefore it needs
to be aligned on the right
rather than on the left.
Describer:
ANOTHER SLIDE IS TITLED
"WebVTT CAPTION POSITIONING."
Pfeiffer: Now, positioning
is another requirement
and, again, something
that traditional captions,
TV captions,
are able to do.
It's possible to position cues
anywhere in WebVTT.
There are basically
three important ways
to position text.
Describer: A STILL SHOT FROM
"ANNIE HALL" FINDS DIANE KEATON
WEARING A DRESS SHIRT,
NECKTIE, AND VEST.
CAPTIONS APPEAR
IN THE CENTER OF THE VIDEO PANE
AT BOTH THE TOP AND BOTTOM
OF THE SCREEN.
THE BOTTOM CAPTION TEXT
WRAPS TO A SECOND LINE.
AFTER THE LINE BREAK,
THE CAPTIONS ARE CENTER ALIGNED.
THE BOTTOM CAPTION READS
"YEAH, I SORT OF DABBLE AROUND,
YOU KNOW."
THE TOP CAPTION: "I DABBLE?
LISTEN TO ME. WHAT A JERK."
HEADINGS NEXT TO THE STILL
READ "L, LINE POSITION,
T, TEXT POSITION
A, ALIGNMENT."
Pfeiffer: There are
line positions.
So the concept of display lines
exists in WebVTT.
So the line position
allows people
to directly address
a specific line.
It can be done with
a line number or a percentage.
Then we have
the text position.
This means we're placing
the text either on the left,
in the middle,
or on the right.
No, hold on.
That's the alignment, sorry.
Alignment is
left, middle, and right.
And the text position is...
so when we have text
like this,
it's in the middle,
and it's centered.
So we can also do a centering,
and we can do
a left alignment
and a right alignment.
But we can also move
that whole text elsewhere.
So the text position
is where we move the text
and the alignment is
where we align it at.
Describer: A SAMPLE FILE
FEATURES POSITION CODES
TO THE RIGHT
OF THE TIME CODE MARKERS.
FOR THE CAPTION AT THE TOP,
THE CODES READ
"A:middle" AND "L:10%".
FOR THE BOTTOM CAPTION,
"A:middle" AND "L:60%".
A NEW SLIDE IS TITLED
"WebVTT SPEAKER SEMANTICS."
TWO FRAMES OF VIDEO FROM
THE ANIMATED PROGRAM "ARTHUR"
CAPTURE A MONKEY
FROWNING AT A BUNNY.
THE FIRST FRAME IS CAPTIONED
"AHEM..."
WITH THE CAPTION LEFT ALIGNED
TO APPEAR BELOW THE MONKEY.
THE SECOND FRAME IS CAPTIONED
"WHAT'S THE MATTER?"
AND IS RIGHT ALIGNED
TO APPEAR BELOW THE BUNNY.
Pfeiffer: We also have
speaker semantics
included into WebVTT,
which is interesting
because it allows us
to put some semantic information
into our markup.
Describer: IN THE SAMPLE FILE,
TAGS APPEAR BEFORE THE TEXT
OF EACH CAPTION,
"v.Beatrix"
IN THE FIRST CAPTION,
AND "v.Arthur"
IN THE SECOND.
THE TAGS ARE NOT CLOSED.
Pfeiffer: Here, for example,
we have two people speaking.
We know their position
on the left and on the right.
And the speaker markup
can tell us where we want
to position it
and can also, for example,
help us always use
the same styling
for the same speaker.
So, for example, we want
to use the same font,
the same font color,
maybe a specific outline
or something for a speaker.
We can define that
and then apply that always
for that speaker.
Describer: ANOTHER SLIDE,
WebVTT TEXT DESCRIPTIONS.
Pfeiffer: Now, so much
for captions.
Now we move on
to a little example
on text descriptions.
Here is one
that I've used previously,
and we've got that
as an example on the site.
Describer: A SAMPLE FILE
CONTAINS THREE DESCRIPTIONS,
EACH WITH THREE LINES
OF INFORMATION:
DESCRIPTION NUMBER,
TIME CODE START AND STOP,
AND THE TEXT TO BE READ ALOUD
BY A SCREEN READER.
THE SLIDE GIVES
THREE SAMPLE DESCRIPTIONS.
SAMPLE ONE, "THE ORANGE OPEN
MOVIE PROJECT PRESENTS."
SAMPLE TWO, "INTRODUCTORY TITLES
ARE SHOWING ON THE BACKGROUND
"OF A WATER POOL
WITH FISHES SWIMMING
AND MECHANICAL OBJECTS
LYING ON A STONE FLOOR."
SAMPLE THREE, "TITLE:
ELEPHANTS DREAM."
Pfeiffer: I'm not gonna
go there;
I just want to mention it,
because we want to focus
on captions today.
But what happens here is,
we've got text that's aligned
with a start and end time
as well.
And for a typical word rate
of a screen reader,
it will fit into that space,
and it will be read back
by the screen reader
during that time.
Describer: A NEW SLIDE,
WebVTT CHAPTERS FOR NAVIGATION.
Pfeiffer: And here is
the navigation example.
As I mentioned, WebVTT can also
be used for navigation.
Here we have three chapters,
and we can directly jump
from chapter to chapter.
There needs to be extra controls
on videos to support this,
but this is something
we're working towards.
Describer: A SAMPLE FILE
CONTAINS THREE CHAPTERS,
EACH WITH THREE LINES
OF INFORMATION:
CHAPTER NUMBER, TIME CODE START
AND STOP, AND CHAPTER TITLE.
TEXT BELOW THE SAMPLE READS
"NAVIGATION MARKERS."
A NEW SLIDE IS TITLED
"TEXT TRACKS IN HTML5."
Pfeiffer: Now, of course,
as I'm saying,
controls and input
into web pages
and automatic rendering,
we need to know
how we're going to do that.
And there is markup
in HTML5
for associating captions
and formats like this
with videos.
In this example,
I've got all of the VTT files
that we've used before.
I've included them here.
And what we're using for it
is called a track element,
and this track element
is included
underneath the video element
in the HTML5 markup.
It links through
the VTT file.
And there is some description
possible
for the type of file it is,
so we have a label.
In this case,
it's an English caption.
We have a kind,
which gives us a means
to group all the tracks
of the same type together.
Describer: A CODE SAMPLE LISTS
A SOURCE VIDEO
AND A SERIES OF TRACKS
WITH THE FOLLOWING LABELS:
ENGLISH CAPTIONS, GERMAN
SUBTITLES, FRENCH SUBTITLES,
ENGLISH DESCRIPTIONS,
AND CHAPTERS.
EACH TRACK HAS ATTRIBUTES "KIND"
"SRC LANG" AND "SRC",
WITH THE "SRC" CONTAINING
A URL TO THE WebVTT FILE.
THE SAMPLE CONTAINS THE KINDS
CAPTIONS, SUBTITLES,
DESCRIPTIONS, AND CHAPTERS.
Pfeiffer: And we identify
the language.
Because, of course, when we have
user settings in browsers,
we want to automatically
make certain tracks
available to the user
if the user has,
for example,
said that they always
want captions
or they always want subtitles
in their language being shown.
So the browser can
look through this markup
and identify which ones
it has to turn on by default.
Describer: AFTER TEXT THAT READS
"SRCLANG="
THE LETTERS "EN"
ARE HIGHLIGHTED,
INDICATING ENGLISH LANGUAGE.
Pfeiffer: Now, in this case,
I've used only WebVTT files.
The track layout, the way that
we've defined track in HTML5,
is actually generic.
It can be used for other types
of files as well,
TTML or SRT
or any other formats
that will be implemented.
Describer: THE WORD "TRACK"
IS HIGHLIGHTED
IN A TAG READING:
TRACK LABEL="ENGLISH CAPTIONS".
Pfeiffer: But the generic way
that track
works is in this way.
Describer: A NEW SLIDE
IS TITLED
"USING CSS FOR RICHER STYLING."
A SAMPLE FILE FEATURES
THE MAN IN HIS WORKSHOP
CAPTIONED "I HEARD ABOUT
THIS ARDUINO PROJECT
AND SAW IT ONLINE."
THE WORD ARDUINO IS RED
AND ALL CAPS.
THE REST OF THE CAPTION
IS BLACK AND MIXED TYPECASE.
Pfeiffer: Now, once we've got it
in the browser,
we can actually support more
than what is directly possible
as markup
in the WebVTT file,
because now we've got the text
in the browser,
and we can make use
of all the functionality
of the browser,
which has styling
and the concurrent style sheet
functionality
available to it.
So this kind of styling
is also available
if used in a browser,
to these cues.
And the way in which
this is being done
is that there's
a pseudo-element in CSS
called ::cue.
And with that pseudo-element,
you can address,
for example,
classes in the cue markup.
Describer: IN THE SAMPLE FILE,
A TAG POINTING TO ".arduino"
SURROUNDS THE WORD ARDUINO.
Pfeiffer: And you can override
the formatting
that by default
would be given.
You can, for example--
well, in this case,
it's been turned red,
uppercase,
a different font family,
and a lighter weight.
Describer: IN A SEPARATE BOX,
UNDER THE HEADING CSS,
THE ::CUE PSEUDO-ELEMENT
".arduino"
CONTAINS CODE SELECTING
COLOR AS RED,
TEXT-TRANSFORM AS UPPERCASE,
FONT-FAMILY AS HELVETICA NEUE,
AND FONT-WEIGHT AS LIGHTER.
A NEW SLIDE IS TITLED
"WebVTT DEFAULT RENDERING."
TWO HEADINGS READ
"POP-ON: BOTTOM THIRD OF VIDEO
VIEWPORT, CENTERED"
AND "ROLL-UP: OVERLAPPING
CAPTIONS ARE ADDED UNDERNEATH."
Pfeiffer: Now, we've
spoken a lot.
We want to see a little bit
of a demo here,
and I've made a little bit
of a demo
which shows that we can
do more than what's typically
being used for captions
right now.
Most captions that are
being used are pop-on captions,
which are captions
that don't overlap in time.
There's one piece of caption,
one cue shown;
it disappears, and the next cue
is brought up.
That's pop-on.
And that is the default way
of rendering it.
But we may have
a very different style
of providing captions
as well,
which has traditionally
been used
mostly in live captioning.
It's called roll-up.
So the cues will actually
be added at the bottom
and roll up as the--
and the old ones
will disappear.
So I've made a little example
that shows how that
can be done as well.
Describer: A VIDEO PLAYS.
AS THE MAN IN HIS SHOP SPEAKS,
TWO LINES OF LEFT-ALIGNED
CAPTIONS
APPEAR TO ROLL UP
FROM THE BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN.
WITH EACH NEW CAPTION,
THE BOTTOM CAPTION MOVES UP
TO THE TOP LINE,
AND THE TOP CAPTION DISAPPEARS.
Pfeiffer: Let's hope this works.
Man: I heard about
this Arduino Project,
and I saw it online,
and I said, "Wow,
"a lot of people are starting
to talk about this.
I should check it out."
Second Man: 'Cause we wanted
to make a tool
for our student
that was more modern
than what was available
on the market at the moment.
Third Man: For me,
it was a case
that this is a tool
that I could see using myself,
and therefore
I could believe
in actually helping to get it
out to a wider world.
Fourth Man:
[speaking foreign language]
Pfeiffer: So you could see
that the captions
were being pushed up
as they were being displayed.
This is a very simple way
of doing
this kind of roll-up.
So as we're moving on,
the next caption
gets added to the bottom.
This can be improved.
This is just
a very crude demo.
But this can be improved
with a bit more CSS
in the browser.
We can, for example, transition
the text more slowly,
and then it would be
more readable,
rather than it
jumping there directly.
There's a whole swag
of CSS functionality
available to us
in the browser
to make this look very nice.
And the functionality is there
and possible to be used.
Describer: A NEW SLIDE,
"EXOTIC: PAINT-ON CAPTIONS."
Pfeiffer: I've mentioned
paint-on and roll-up captions.
I've mentioned pop-on
and roll-up captions.
I want to briefly also mention
paint-on captions,
even though that's a bit more
of an exotic use case.
But it's possible to be used
in CEA-608 captions,
so we need to make sure
that it's also possible
to be represented in WebVTT.
And what we've introduced
for this kind of application
is cue timestamps.
These cue timestamps
are basically just a timestamp
that is being included
into the text
and says when the text
that comes afterwards
will be activated.
Describer: A SAMPLE FILE
CONTAINS CAPTION NUMBER,
CAPTION START
AND STOP TIME CODES,
AND INDIVIDUAL CAPTIONED WORDS
SEPARATED BY TIMESTAMP CODES.
THE TIMESTAMPS THEMSELVES
ARE ENCLOSED IN ANGLE BRACKETS.
BELOW, HEADINGS READ
"CUE TIMESTAMPS"
"CHARACTER RESOLUTION POSSIBLE"
"STYLING THROUGH
CSS PSEUDO-SELECTORS"
AND ":PAST, :FUTURE
(E.G. KARAOKE)."
Pfeiffer: Here I've done it--
[coughs]
pardon me--
at the word level.
I've put cue timestamps in
for every word,
so every word would come up
one after the other
on the screen.
However, the resolution
is arbitrary.
We could do that
on every character if necessary.
Interestingly enough,
that can also be used
for styling through CSS.
There are the past and future
pseudo-selectors.
And these selectors allow us,
for example,
to do something like
paint the old text in yellow,
the new text in white.
Describer: SILVIA HIGHLIGHTS
THE ":PAST" PSEUDO-SELECTOR,
THEN POINTS OUT A CODE SAMPLE
WITH THE HEADING CSS.
IT CONTAINS TWO EXPRESSIONS
MAKING PAST CUE COLORS YELLOW
AND ADDING A TEXT SHADOW
TO FUTURE CUES.
Pfeiffer: With a text shadow,
and as it goes over,
everything goes yellow.
And we know this kind
of application, obviously,
from karaoke,
which bridges into
these applications as well,
into more modern
time-aligned text applications.
We can cover
all of these use cases
with the same approach.
So that brings me
to the end of the presentation.
Describer: ANOTHER SLIDE
IS TITLED
"WebVTT, A BRIDGE BETWEEN
BROADCAST AND THE WEB."
POINTS BELOW READ: "FULL
FEATURES OF CEA-608 CAPTIONS"
"SIMPLICITY OF EDITING"
"ABILITY TO APPLY WEB STYLING"
AND "OPEN AND FREELY AVAILABLE."
Pfeiffer: We regard WebVTT as
a bridge between broadcast
and the web of the future.
We can support
all of the CEA-608 captions,
all of the features,
possibly also
some of the 708 features--
I think most of them;
I haven't analyzed in detail.
But most of the 708 features
will be supported as well.
It's a simplicity
of editing,
which we like
about the WebVTT format.
It's readable.
You can read it here on screen.
There's not too much busyness
as you're looking at it.
And that means also
that it's easy to edit
and to create.
We have the ability
to apply web styling
through the track mechanism
that has been included
into HTML5.
And this is an open
and freely available format.
If you're looking
for references,
I've put the references
on this last slide
to all the specs.
They're available for free.
Thank you very much.
Describer: NAOMI RETURNS
TO THE PODIUM.
[applause]
Black: So thank you, Silvia.
We have a mic up if people
want to ask any questions.
Maybe you could introduce
yourself briefly.
We're recording this,
and we're gonna be
posting it to YouTube,
so hopefully
you won't be shy.
But please, if you have
any questions for Silvia
about WebVTT,
please step up to the mic.
Pfeiffer: I was going
very quickly,
so if somebody wants
to go back
and explore any of the features
in more detail,
this is probably
the opportunity.
Steinberg: Hi,
I'm Daniel Steinberg at Google.
A couple questions.
When you had the line number
specification,
how does that apply
when you have vertical text?
Pfeiffer:
Let me just find that.
Here, this one?
Steinberg: Yeah.
Describer: SILVIA CUES
THE "CAPTION POSITION" SLIDE
THAT HIGHLIGHTS LINE POSITION,
TEXT POSITION,
AND ALIGNMENT FEATURES.
Pfeiffer: So the line numbers
are basically done in--
for horizontal text,
obviously from the top
to the bottom.
And for vertical text,
they are turned around.
So they apply in the same way.
Steinberg: Okay, and you have
a lot of the underpinnings
for interactive text,
but not the actual--
I didn't see anything
actually there.
So the ability to say
this particular tag is live,
and clicking on it might give
a link or something like that.
Have you considered
interactivity?
Pfeiffer: Interactivity--
you particularly talking
about hyperlinks in this case?
Steinberg:
In this case, yes.
Pfeiffer: Yes, so hyperlinks
is something of a bit
of a controversial issue.
We've discussed this.
It is obviously something
that can easily be added.
We've got the markup
in HTML5.
We could easily put a "a" tag
in there and a hyperlink.
It's not something
that's currently part
of the specification simply
because people don't believe
that it's a very good
experience.
When you're watching captions,
they stay on the screen
only for a very short
amount of time.
By the time you've decided
that you want to follow a link,
it's already gone.
That's the reason.
So I'm obviously not fully
subscribed to that reason.
I would actually like to have
hyperlinks in it as well.
What I look at in this format
is that it's easy to extend it,
and if somebody
was to support it,
then it is not a problem
to put that in as well.
Steinberg: Yeah, something
to consider with the hyperlinks
is that, because
you have the ability
to author
different kinds of files,
you could have a description
that had a longer time
and had a longer duration.
It wouldn't
have to disappear
when a caption line
disappeared.
Pfeiffer: In fact,
I should actually add something.
We've got, as I mentioned,
we've got kinds of text
that we're expecting
in a WebVTT file.
I've talked about
captions and subtitles,
text descriptions,
and I've talked about
navigation.
I've only mentioned metadata,
but metadata actually
solves that problem.
Metadata means that
you're allowed to put anything
into a cue:
any markup you want,
any non-markup you want,
any text, anything at all.
It just means that the browser
can't do anything with it.
It decides--it sees that
it's of the kind "metadata"
and goes,
"I'm being hands-off.
"I'm just gonna hand it on
to the JavaScript,
and the JavaScript can do
with it whatever it likes."
So this would be one way
to have interactivity in it.
You could just
grab it through JavaScript
and then put it into a div
on your page,
and then there would be
a hyperlink.
And anything else
that you can come up with
that's time-aligned would
work in a similar way as well.
Steinberg:
And one last question.
You showed
the different formats--
captions and descriptions
and whatnot--
as essentially the same
VTT format,
distinguished only
by the track tag.
And I wonder if there's
enough semantic difference
that you'd want to be able to
distinguish it in another way.
Like, for instance,
would you build a--
could you build a file
that had captions
and descriptions in it?
Or might you want to have
some identifier in the file say,
"This is a description file,"
rather than count on
the track tag?
Pfeiffer: Mixing content
in one track
is of course possible.
Like, you could concatenate,
for example,
a caption file with
an audio description file.
Then you would basically
have two tracks available
through one file.
It's not a very easy way
to deal with,
and it would require a lot
of additional implementation.
So, for example,
if that concatenated case
was to be handled,
the browsers
would need to find out
where the second file starts
and so on.
We actually like to keep
the semantics separate.
And HTML markup is built
on keeping semantics separate.
So this is why we introduced
the "kind" attribute.
And so therefore,
in one file,
you will only find captions
of one type.
Thank you.
Foliot: Hi, Silvia.
John Foliot
from Stanford University.
When you gave
the code example of the CSS,
it's not clear where
the CSS actually lives.
Is it embedded
in the WebVTT file?
Can you have an external file
and link it?
Can you just maybe get into that
a little bit further?
Pfeiffer: Yeah, let me
just find it. Sorry.
So I've deliberately just
put that there as a snippet,
because it actually
doesn't matter where it lives.
Describer: SYLVIA PULLS UP
THE "USING CSS
FOR RICHER STYLING" PAGE,
WITH THE ::CSS PSEUDO-ELEMENT
IN A SEPARATE TEXT BOX
FROM THE WebVTT FILE.
Pfeiffer: At the moment,
because we're doing the CSS
through the HTML page,
that includes
this file up there...
that HTML page could
either have this CSS piece
directly in the HTML page
and address it--
so an in-band CSS.
Or it could be in
an external CSS file
and be pulled into
the HTML page
together with
the WebVTT file.
Foliot: So it always sits
outside of the VTT file.
Pfeiffer: It can.
Yeah, well...
So we're currently
under discussion
whether this
is a functionality
that we'd want to add
to WebVTT as well.
So whether you want
a WebVTT file
that links
to a style sheet.
We're careful about that
because we--
this comes from
a very web point of view.
We don't really want to pollute
the WebVTT file
with this web functionality,
because there are applications
outside the web browser
that do not want to have
to implement,
for example,
all of CSS style sheets
in order to display
captions properly.
So it probably
makes more sense
to have this
as a separate file.
And if people do want to have
this additional functionality,
they can use
the WebVTT file
and the CSS file together
and parse them, and use them
in their style sheet engine
to come up
with the proper display.
Black: I actually,
I have a practical example
of why you would want
the CSS.
Is this on?
Can you hear me?
Pfeiffer: Yes.
Black: I have
a practical example
of why you would want
the CSS to be outside the VTT.
I work currently with people
who are producing caption files
for the UK market
and who are then redistributing
that same video here in the US,
and they have to basically
redo the entire caption file
because UK audiences
are expecting, for instance,
to see a particular speaker
marked up in a particular color.
Here in the US,
we're not expecting that.
So you could imagine
if you had one format
where you marked up
the content semantically
that, depending on whether
you showed it in a player
here for the US
or there for the UK
with the same caption file,
you could display it
differently
according to different users'
regional preferences.
Foliot: I would also add
that user style sheets,
the user could actually
increase the font size
to their
specific requirements.
Pfeiffer: Yes.
Foliot: A second,
really minor question.
On the alignment,
you said it could be
left, right, or--
was it
middle or center?
Can you actually
have it justified as well?
Pfeiffer: No.
I don't think we have
a means to justify the text.
But I also think that,
actually--
so from all the quality captions
literature that I've read,
how to do quality captions,
I think justification
has never been proposed
as a readable way
of doing it
because it changes
the spacing between characters
and so therefore makes the text
actually harder to read.
Foliot: I agree.
Pfeiffer: I don't think we
actually need that feature.
But it is
a good point, yeah.
Foliot: Well, it just wasn't
specifically declared
one way or the other.
I agree with you.
Pfeiffer: Yeah, okay, fine.
Excellent.
Have we got
any more questions?
Well, thank you very much.
I suppose if anyone
has any more questions,
we're always here
to answer more questions.
There's the Accessibility Group
at Google,
through which Naomi
can be reached.
And I'm very active
at the W3C.
Feedback can be sent also
to the WHAT Working Group.
There's plenty of ways
to get to us.
I should have probably put
a contact slide in there
as well.
I'm also on Twitter
and Facebook and so on.
But just Google my name,
Silvia Pfeiffer.
You'll find me.
Thank you very much.
[applause]